i want you to think about somebody named
alexander the great who conquered two
million square miles and he was the most
incredible greatest leader
general we ever had and this guy's
crushing it
and then all of a sudden after two
million square miles he comes back
and he has so much idol time he starts
drinking
partying celebrating until he kills
himself at the age of 33.
do you know why because he got so much
success and he had no clue what to do
after retain the success
because he made one mistake he didn't
know what was his next
they put it through this or what i mean
by he didn't know what his next was your
biggest enemy sometimes when you're
winning in life is winning
i had a conversation the other day with
a group of our guys and i said listen
guys let me tell you what i
uh uh watch for people i watch people
and
see how they win because it's so easy to
win you know you watch people who win
some of them when they're like well let
me tell you who i am i'm this this is
very few people know how to win most
people who win
they don't have a next milestone right
afterwards mario and i were having a
conversation
the mario asked me a question says pat
how do you
what is it about the people that you see
that keep advancing what do they do i
said
every single time they reach a goal or a
milestone
immediately they have their next goal
already set up
immediately they have their necks set up
most people don't have it immediately
most people go and go and go and go and
go boom they hit something oh my gosh
i can't believe it guess what two months
of celebration
boom and then to bring it back up
it's twice the effort because you got to
recreate that momentum that took
years to create you lost that momentum
recreating momentum is a very
very heavy task you got to go through it
all over again
and this happens to the greatest of the
greatest who don't
sit there and identify their necks and
by the way this is not your next move
this is your next goal this is your next
target
this is your next milestone so i'll come
back to you
maybe recently you had a victory what is
your next
and by the way this is not other
people's jobs
this isn't somebody else's job to sit
you down and identify your next
this is your job other people can be a
source of inspiration you can say well i
wish i had somebody pat
that would tell me what i need to be
doing next then that means you're a
follower there's a part of you
eventually in life you got to have those
private conversation and say
my next goal is dot dot dot
if you get to a point where every single
time you reach a new marker
he's like dude this was amazing this
felt so great
huh you know what i'm going for boom
boom boom
next and here why next 5 10 15 moves to
get to
my next goal phenomenal fire again
if you don't have that every single time
you're going to do this every single
time you're going to do this
it's one of the most frustrating things
by the way
you know you you get what you want
you're winning all the stuff that
happens
alexander's enemy was what idol time
idle time it sucks it's scary
it's a drug because idle time you're
sitting there
and there's time to think don't get me
wrong there's time for you to sit there
and think and strategize
but some people have way too much idle
time and they have too much shell on
their hands oh
people do stupid things you can do ten
years
focus dedicated you did everything right
and all of a sudden
too much idle time not knowing how to
handle victory not having your necks
identified
everything disappears ten years you
build it
idle time ruined everything for you so
whoever you are watching this right now
saying pat
this message is a little bit scary it's
actually not scary just got every single
time you win put your next milestone in
place and say
i'm going after this thing and if you
don't have one right now after watching
this video take a few
moments to yourself and say what's my
next thing i'm going after
and if it fires you up go chase it if
you don't come up with it
that idle time is going to get you to go
backwards having said that if you've
never watched a video i made how to plan
your next 15 moves click over you to
watch it
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel do so thanks for watching
[Music]
everybody